nouvel album s'appelle parce qu'on vient
de loin
c'est la totale à sonia rolland veolia
leur promo il ya tout là c'est la totale
chez ardisson alors l'album s'appelle
parce qu'on vient de loin c'est vrai que
vous venez de voir vous venez du rwanda
et votre vrai nom cormeilles c'est
cornelius nyungura exactement là j'ai
bien des biens volés le est gênant c'est
mieux mais comme tout le monde je
voudrais un petit peu de votre gueule
quand vous étiez petit on vous a appelé
corneille tout simplement alors votre
père et tutsis et votre mère et août
exactement drame familial c'était à
kigali donc que vous avez commencé à
faire de la de la musique en écoutant
boys tumen et la première compo de
corneille c'était l'âge de 15 ans piano
est donc assez assez précoce à 16 ans
vont remporter un concours découverte de
la télévision rwandaise une espèce de
graines de stars on peut dire ça c'était
la première année de la télévision au
rang d'un la terrifiante aérien peu
tardivement nous en 93 et
on avait on avait 16 ans puis on s'est
retrouvé troisième avec des gens qui
avait 15 ans de métier c'est
encourageant or voilà donc début de
carrière comme ça très très très
prometteur et malheureusement anéanti
par le génocide le 15 avril 1994 vous
êtes en famille dans votre maison de
kigali quand les soldats font irruption
quel soldat je ne sais juste
qu'aujourd'hui pas qui étaient ces
militaires là il ya plusieurs hypothèses
ça peut être des militaires de 2 à
l'époque du fr on l'appeler l'armée
rebelle qui aujourd'hui la l'armée au
pouvoir aujourd'hui et ça pourrait bien
être aussi l'autre camp dont on s'est
envoyé rentrer des gens un jour dans le
salon de vos parents et vous savez
toujours pas qui c'était finalement
c'est désormais on savait pas qui était
alors il vous réunissent dans la même
pièce il vous fusille à bout portant
vous sauver in extremis votre peau en
plongeant derrière un divan du salon
mais vos parents vos trois frères vos
trois soeurs meurt sous les coups de ses
soldats voilà vous retrouver unique
rescapé de ce massacre vous vous cachez
au départ quelques jours à kigali
s'étaient ambigus comme situation
c'était très absurde en même temps
bon c'est ridicule on est parmi les
rares pays au monde où dans ta carte
d'identité ouais on
explique bien de quelle ethnie on a
partirai c'est un truc
c'est complètement aberrant et donc le
premier critère pour y avait des
barrages dont je de miliciens ou de
l'armée le premier critère donc c'était
ton appartenance ethnique par rapport à
ce qu'il ya dans ta carte d'identité
mais ça s'est vite ça les gens avaient
plus le temps de faire ce tri d'un et en
regardant les cartes d'identité tout ça
donc après c'était selon la famille
c'était au faciès exactement et moi j'ai
plus gardés du physique de mon père est
donc tout c'est exactement tout si donc
c'était c'est un peu plus difficile donc
il a fallu que je me cache évidemment un
mais ça ne m'a pas empêché de vivre le
génocide donc sur le terrain en mode ya
donc vous cacher quelques jours à kigali
et puis vous mêlés au flot des réfugiés
des des centaines comme ça de milliers
de gens qui marchent sur les routes vers
le congo sur 50 km on est un petit peu
comme des automates quoi des gens qui
avaient des automates série de telles
horreurs qu'ils marchaient d'une façon
assez mécanique c'était c'est exactement
ça c'était c'était
c'était automatique c'est elle la sueur
y voilà je pense que c'est humain ouais
le l'instinct de survie qui prend le
dessus et ont mis en marche leur marche
tout droit fait 150 km alors ensuite
évidemment grâce à des amis de vos
parents vous rejoignez l'allemagne vous
passez un petit peu tôt en allemagne
ensuite vous allez au canada vous allez
à 1 montréal et là vous continuez à
faire de la musique et vous faites un
groupe qui s'appelle one nous fait un
morceau qui marche très très bien car la
chapelle zukin
doha
je suis sûr c'est la première fois que
vous leur en attendait depuis 2000
canada le canada mais ça fait longtemps
ça fait toujours tourner du mal à le
retrouver alors numéro un donc sur les
erp les canadiens zouk une avec le
groupe one et là vous réalisez en fait
corneille que vous avez quelque chose à
dire qui ne peut pas passer par par un
groupe ça peut passer uniquement par
votre expression personnelle
c'est-à-dire par une carrière solo et
vous fait cet album dont on a parlé tout
à l'heure qui s'appelle parce qu'on
vient de loin et vous dites je dédie mon
album aux gens qui se sentent oubliés
par le reste du monde c'est vrai dit
vous et vous avez raison on a beaucoup
parlé du 11-septembre bien sûr on a
beaucoup plus parlé du génocide du
rwanda
qui a été le plus gros génocide après le
low cost après la shoah quoi c'est vrai
du temps pour préparer durant 70 gelé
j'ai vécu cet événement là de façon
complètement différemment j'ai touché en
revanche au canada que je en amérique du
nord j'avais de la peine pour les
familles qui avaient perdu les leurs ce
qui est complètement normal mais quand
même temps j'avais un sentiment de
dégoût
on s'est levés le 11 septembre il y
avait des banques qui défilent et en
vrac de tous les écrans avec les
différents donc la ville de new york
ouais obtenez donc pour suite à ces
événements là et il ya eu des milliers
de morts
au rwanda et plus d'un million de morts
plus d'un million de morts donc ce con
con on est au courant et
je sais ça ça m'a amené à me poser la
question est ce que selon l'endroit où
dit on et où on vit est ce que la vie un
être humain vaut plus cher un gros à
l'autre et gt ça m'a beaucoup c'est un
problème pour moi c'était vraiment un
problème pour moi vous êtes retourné au
rwanda depuis n'ont malheureusement pas
mais j'ai l'intention de dire on va
revoir le clip parce que quelqu'un
dedans qui est très jolie